- Two, that's a fun age sometimes.
Terrible twos yet?
- Not yet?
Well-
- I didn't get terrible twos.
I got three-nager.
- That's what I'm scared
is that it's just delayed
and I keep saying she's perfect
and then she's gonna sneak up on me.
She's super joyful.
Meow was her first word,
but her other word is no.
She's a totally unreliable narrator.
- She's just, "no."
She'll be eating watermelon
and I'll say, "Oh, is that watermelon?"
"No."
(audience laughs)
- She's already
gaslighting her.
She's already gaslighting her!
- At young age.
- Kids are the-
- She does it with the cutest voice.
- That's gaslighting;
- (indistinct) it.
So now 15 years from now,
she's been encouraged to
act like this by her mother.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh. my gosh.
I love, I miss-
I don't miss as I-
I love every age.
But mine are seven and nine at this point.
And it's like you just-
I was out trick-or-treating with them
and seeing all
these little kids
- I know.
- Those little costumes.
Aw.
- It's very cozy.
- Very dangerous.
(Barbara laughs)
'cause I did not need more children.
(audience laughs)
I was already a single mom, but-
You have one boy and two girls, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, so I have a boy and a girl.
That's very different.
Are you experiencing that?
- My gosh.
When Hal entered the equation,
it was like we didn't
even know what to do.
It was like all this boy energy
that our house kind of needed
'cause it was a lot of girl things, vibes.
- But boys are like tasmanian devils.
- [Jenna] Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- No, he leads with his head.
- He was also a New York
City rat for Halloween,
(audience laughs)
- Which is kind of awesome.
- [Barbara] Which is awesome.
- The foreshadowing of who he's gonna be
is pretty magical, right?
(all laugh)
It's like, "Alright. I love that."
- He's not afraid to be himself for sure.
- Yeah, mine loves scary
and I think that's
insane. 'cause he's seven.
But he was like, "Mom, take a picture."
Everything just horribly scary.
He was like, "Take a picture, take video."
I was like, "Why?"
- So we can watch this?
So we can look back over.
- That was like later, yeah.
But he loves it.